foreign
mom for the last 15 plus years and want
to return to work so I can get out of my
abusive marriage I had a work colleague
who helped me get a job and I'm just
really scared that I'm going to fail not
want to let my kids down
[Music]
what is going on this is John with the
Dr John deloney show show about your
marriage and your mental health and your
kids and whatever else you got going on
in your life
been doing this for two decades sitting
with people and the wheels have fallen
off and my promise is I mean I know the
answer but I'm gonna tell you the truth
and I'll sit here with you if you want
to be on the show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask
still it feels like forever now building
a non-anxious life my brand new book is
out for pre-sale go to John deloney.com
it's 20 bucks we'll send you all kind of
shenanigans and uh you can download some
talk right away and audio books if
you're not a reader it'll it'll get you
the audiobook too
um some of these are autographed I don't
know how they're doing all that stuff
but anyway I just know I got lots of
books to sign but go to John deloney.com
thank you so so so much for picking this
thing up um you'll know we record this
show ahead of time so we've been
recording for several weeks that the
book's coming out and had to pretend
like hey it's coming out but it really
wasn't out yet it's kind of like uh Back
to the Future When Future me meets old
me but the books actually been into
pre-sale in real life
as of right now and the numbers are
astounding they're they're it's mad
house and everyone's just walking around
here smiling
I'm walking around a little bit of
disbelief
um thank you for those of you who picked
this up thank you so much
um I'm just so grateful I can't hardly
even breathe
um but if you haven't yet go to John
delaney.com pick it up 20 bucks and um
I think it's gonna help change your life
it's gonna help change your life let's
go out to Christian in h-tone in Houston
go Astros what's up Christian
hey John how are you partying man what
are you up to
not much just trying to find a decent
room
not partying how can I help man what's
going on
uh well my question was um
how can I control my emotions so that
they don't come out
I guess in a negative way towards my
life
tell me more what happened
so
we just
it's been a little over a month and uh
we've been living together for
over three years now and it's been hold
on hold on what's what's been over
what's been over a little over a month
uh our mayor sorry oh you just got
married you're newlywed yeah newlywed
yep one month in
yeah a little over one month in got made
uh June 24th okay and uh got married
June 24th and you've been in for a month
you've been living together for three
years
about well we've been together for three
years but living together for about a
year okay
and um how are your emotions coming out
on your wife in a negative way
uh so it's it's
got called to my attention by her um
a few a week and a half ago that
sometimes I'll get a little over the top
irritated and it'll come out as Miguel
or me talking in a louder fashion than I
used to I guess um
and I
I've noticed it now too that sometimes I
get
a lot of things in the back of my head
and just coming out and
a more it's a more heavier tone than I
have used to been talking to her and I
I want I guess help on how
can I not be like that because I mean
we just we just started so I just want
to be a good husband and I appreciate
that man I appreciate that the um the
first step here is ownership
and the way you described it out of the
gate to me is
your wife noticed it not me so I'm gonna
ask you and do me a favor speak directly
into the phone let's just have like a
like a manoimano text into text and talk
here
are you yelling at your wife are you
raising your voice are you finding
yourself all pissed off for reasons that
even you're like why am I so mad
yes uh yeah why how come
I
it's hard I I'm not entirely sure
because there's
I mean I can't say I have much to
complain about it's been
but you are so so where does that come
from is it is it a sense of she should
be doing something different is it
you suddenly feel like you can't breathe
because you're married like you're a
husband just adjusting to that role and
that title which is kind of weird
um did she bait and switch you did she
date you for three years and all of a
sudden she's all different now like what
where is that coming from
no she's she's amazing uh I just
I think it's more so
I guess the chain there's we're doing a
lot of change right now like
right now I'm actually in our in my
in-laws place oh no she's
um at BLC or uh NCO school because we're
both in the military
but she's away for a bit and I guess hey
stop stop real quick you've been married
for a month and you're living at your
in-laws house and you're wondering why
you're snapping at your wife are you
kidding me man
they I I mean we
I've been with them a lot of times
before and uh they're great I it's just
it's been a I guess a lot of change with
we're planning and we've everything
between the wedding and her going to the
school then moving it all happened I
guess in a span of maybe two
two months so I guess maybe that
combined with the
this new role might have
put a higher toll on me than everyone
how have you um
have you continued to take care of
yourself
and when I say take care of yourself
um
once a week going to meet with a group
of guys just to hang out go to shoot
shoot pool or throw darts or Bible study
whatever you're into
um or go ride skateboards do you still
exercise are you just coming home and
plopping down and watching TV a lot like
like how are you taking care of yourself
uh well I used to
as in I think it's been a month since I
went to the gym talking to the phone
talking to the phone
uh I am this is the room's not great but
uh sorry
you said for the last you said for the
last month
yeah the last month I guess I haven't
been
doing the things that I normally do like
go to the gym or
uh I mean I haven't played video games
because it's something I used to take
the stress out but
it's just
it was I mean I was focused on
I wanted to help her out because she had
to she's also now officially in her she
just
uh graduated and took her and clerks and
passed it and I guess for that time I
just
focused on trying to do like help her
out as much as I could with whatever she
needed whether it be like studying
moving or
anything just be there and
I've
I didn't really have a group of guys to
hang out with uh while I was there I was
kind of more just
trying to do stuff by myself so so thank
you so think of it this way think of
this way what you did was pretty noble
it's pretty good I'm proud of you
um
it's common especially when you're
trying to get your footing and figure
out how to be the best husband you could
be
um
that I'm trying to think of a of a way I
can explain it
um
I'll just use the the analogy that
everybody uses that they tell you on the
plane right that when there's an
emergency and the oxygen falls out
you're supposed to put yours on first
before you start messing with your kids
and your spouse because if you suffocate
and die then everybody dies right and so
what you've done for the last month is
Honorable
you just held your breath and you made
sure that your wife had oxygen tank
after oxygen tank after oxygen tank and
my guess is if she's just now graduating
she had to do finals she had to go
through NCO stuff she had to finish up
all of her end of semester projects and
paperwork and all that stuff and you're
living with your in-laws and now you're
a husband and that just sounds like you
look down and see that ring on your
finger it just feels and sounds weird
right all this is changing and weird
and in an effort to be the best guy you
could be
you made a mistake that all of us make
which is I'm gonna sacrifice myself
completely where I've got nothing left
in the tank because I'm going to
dedicate all of my tank to her
but then you're going to realize that
you got nothing to give
right you can't get what you don't have
and so it doesn't surprise me that you
look up and you don't have any guys to
hang out with for the last month or two
you haven't been to the gym in a month
you're probably eating take out every
night you're living with your in-laws
like there's so much stress there and it
comes out in blame it comes out in a
little sharp even if even if you have
like if your wife's sick all right I've
been married 21 years your wife's sick
and man you just your husband's sick
nobody wants him to be sick but after a
week it's like ah you just come out you
know it's just that feeling I'm not mad
at anybody but it's just kind of Snappy
right and you have to just be conscious
of it so
um I'm gonna give you a couple of things
that I think would really help you is
that cool
yeah please by the way
um did you have a good role model was
your old man a good role model
uh uh well
my dad kind of
family comes from divorce and then my
stepdad uh he's better now but I guess
growing up he wasn't the best role model
okay
um I want you to start practicing
speaking of the period at the end of
your sentence
okay okay not like a kinda I guess kind
of you know like you know man like I
don't
I want you to say I'm Christian from
Houston Texas
my stepdad was not a good guy
he's gotten better as he's gotten you
see the like the the Declaration the
confidence the period at the end of the
sentence not a dot dot dot not a
lipstick into the sentence okay and yeah
I want you to say I'm gonna I'm gonna be
the best husband I can be
and what a sacrificial husband does is
he makes sure he's strong and well so
that he can go in there and be of
service
so he can help
and so I want you to make sure you're
getting back in the gym I want you to
make sure you got a group of guys you
can hang out with even if it's going to
be weird and you just invite a few guys
out to get nachos or beers or whatever
y'all do
um in town there
when do you and your wife get back into
the same zip code
uh uh at the end of the month she comes
back on the 24th okay she gets back at
the end of the month when she comes back
I want you to take her out
one just just privately just y'all two
one to celebrate this is awesome it's
amazing congratulations
number two
to tell her I want to be the best
husband you can ever dream of
and I'm kind of Flying Blind here
because I don't I didn't have that
growing up
and so let's do this thing together and
here Christian if you can get this down
as a newlywed man this will change the
rest of your life okay if you can sit
with her and say
how can I love you this week
as you start your new job as we find an
apartment as we both go back to Service
as we whatever we're doing
how can I love you best this week and
here's another gift you can give her
here's what I need this week you as a
man if you can come up with the courage
and the bravery and the strength to say
out loud what you need
I need some time to go to the gym I need
some time for us to what whoa I need
some like what do you need what do you
need I want us to have a date night this
week I want to take you out on a date
will you make a budget with me like what
are these things that you need I think
that'd be incredible and we're just
gonna do this on a weekly bi-weekly
basis and if you guys can begin to
practice having this meeting on a weekly
basis
it will change your marriage forever
last homework assignment my brother is
you have to find one or two men who've
been married a long time and that you
look up to and ask them hey guys can I
take you out to coffee can I take you
out for a drink I want to learn the
secrets
I'm a new husband I'm figuring this out
live and I want to learn how to do this
well can I pick your brain
and man I I would be so honored if
somebody asked me that like hey can I go
learn about how to do this I think that
would be fantastic ma'am but it's your
job to reach out and find some good
mentors some good coaches think of it
this way
um you just got a job in the NBA
as a professional basketball player but
you've never seen a game of basketball
played well you've never seen it you've
never seen Michael Jordan play you've
never seen Hakeem Olajuwon the greatest
of all time play you've never seen
anybody play
how in the world can you play basketball
if you've never seen it done same with
being a husband if you did not have a
good picture of that growing up you
cannot just make it up out of thin air
or off Tick Tock videos
you got to get some real men in your
life that you sit down with on some sort
of regular basis maybe once a month once
every six months maybe just once at one
one at a time that's all the time they
got I'm gonna pick your brain I'm gonna
learn from you I wanna I wanna Implement
some things and come back to you dude
that'd be fantastic so hang on the line
here's my my wedding gift to you I'm
gonna give you a couple of things
number one I'm gonna give you a copy of
both on your past change your future and
building a non-anxious life my two books
I'm gonna hook you guys up for free I
want you to read them together it's
going to talk about what happened when
you're kids and it's gonna cast a vision
into the future for your marriage the
second thing I'm going to give you is
Financial Peace University and a year
subscription to every dollar okay a year
subscription this is a budgeting app and
this sounds like I don't need budgeting
app listen
this is simply a tool for couples to use
to bring themselves to the table
together once a week
and people think like budgeting
budgeting business about money no no
it's way more about that because if you
sit down and do a budget then you have
to talk about priorities you should talk
about needs you have to talk about what
do you want you have to talk about I
don't like this
you have to have all those messy
conversations that's why budgeting sucks
it's hard because it's not just about
dollars and cents it's about
self-control and discipline and
priorities
so I'm going to send that to you it's a
links up to your bank it's almost need
the premium one for a year man it seems
it syncs up to your bank that's my
wedding gift to you and Financial Peace
just gonna give you guys a road map to
getting together with money which again
man if couples will get together with
money it forces them to have some hard
conversations and it gets them on the
same page with almost everything
I'm proud of you man I'm proud of you
Christian
last thing I'll say
never ever yell at your wife
make that a red letter line for you
I will not yell at my wife I'll hang up
the phone I'll walk away I'll go for a
walk I will not yell at my wife make
that a a a a personhood it's your
identity
and then go from there thank you my
brother we'll be right back
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling Hollow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hollow.com deloney today to get three
months of hollow for free
hello.com deloney
all right let's go out to Shea in verbit
for
forbina Virginia Beach
Virginia Beach Hooked on Phonics worked
for me what's up Shay
hey John how are you today I'm not
speaking very clearly but other man I'm
doing great what's happening yeah I
can't either
nothing too much I was just hoping to
pick your brain today on the mental
health of law students so not great not
great all right so it's actually not for
me
um as a wife of a law student how can I
help and protect my husband's mental
health so and I can give some
backgrounds yeah give me some background
okay so we got married four months ago
so we're newlyweds as well
um last week we just moved States for
the school so this is his first time
away from family and friends that he's
known you know his whole life so that's
going to be a big adjustment
um we're going into the first year law
school so he starts this month
um and my biggest concern is that he's
had a history of anxiety and depression
last year he went through like two
months that was pretty deep and that was
like his biggest
um bout of anxiety and depression and he
got checked out by the doctor went to a
therapist got a lot of tools to get
better and went continued and improved
from there and we never had issues since
then but now we're in a place where
there's actual Seasons we're from
Florida so
winter doesn't happen so I'm kind of
concerned about seasonal depression and
you know first year of marriage and law
school's hard so just what are some tips
and insight that you have from your
experience that myself my husband and us
together can Implement so his mental
health is intact over this next couple
of years oh man all right so
I got a lot I got a lot of opinions is
that okay okay
fine probably what I'm gonna do is I'm
just going to start rattling off a bunch
of things and you can just pull this
clip and y'all can watch it together
okay okay
um
because they're probably too much just
to write down while you're on the phone
um so you know I was a dean of students
at a law school and my research was in
the mental health of attorneys and so I
spent
um
in the academic world whether it was
professional conferences or academic
conferences like I lived and breathed
the mental health of lawyers and law
students that was my that was my thing
for years okay and so
um
it's incredible that y'all are this much
on on the front end of this
most of the time a newlyweds Waltz into
the law school everybody's excited I
married a lawyer it's gonna be great and
then about four months into school
everything falls apart okay so here's um
here's number one he has to this is a no
if ands or buts he has to get Mental
Health Resources before school starts
okay that can be through the university
that can be through a local counselor
it's worth the money even if you don't
have it
and I tell you that because law school
is very very hard
and it's hard both academically but it's
hard in a way that if
it's competitive too which makes it
really challenging because it's not just
a matter of learning the material it's
learning the material better than the
person next to you
and more thoroughly and that just adds a
level of of complexity and challenge to
this that is very different than any
other
um academic endeavor
actually
well it's actually a Christian
and so their the competitiveness is a
lot lower and they're more supportive so
we're in the best situation that we can
be for law school and we do like
yeah well I would tell you like even if
it's a faith-based law school I hope
it's competitive because what here's the
deal I I don't want an attorney
that is not competitive taking care of
me if I get hit by a big trucking
company and their attorney went to NYU
and knows how to fight and Claw and
scratch I don't want a nice attorney
representing me you know what I mean
yeah you're gonna get squashed and so
hopefully maybe pedagogically they're
changing like the the instruction there
is some literature that suggests that
competitive does not help that
competitive competition does not help
people learn at all in fact it restricts
learning
um and so there is maybe that's what
they're going after but I hope he's not
going into a law school that's just like
um patchy on the back I hope it's super
super rigorous because he's gonna be
representing clients that need him to be
an assassin that's what that's what
that's what a lawyer does right fights
your client he's got that fire but
yes so the challenge most people are
caught off guard by this they walk into
law school and they were really really
smart they were the smartest kids in
their class in other areas not always
but often
law school is not something you can just
study for the night before right you
start worry studying for finals the
first day of class
and so as his wife you need to know that
when he says he's busy this is unlike
anything you'll have ever experienced
like read
the Harry Potter book every single night
for the whole semester right and not
only know that but know every character
and be able to know what that character
was about to do when a professor calls
on you and has you stand up and talk for
45 minutes on what that character was
doing so it's not even a matter of just
getting through the reading like all of
us did in undergrad this is about
internalizing it and knowing it okay so
I tell you that to tell you many
um
many husbands and wives and girlfriends
and boyfriends of law students and
lawyers
don't have a context for just how hard
this is and so they start to feel left
out like they're exaggerating like
they're kind of lying it is that hard
okay
the third thing I'll tell you is you
need to get a group of friends ASAP
I know God you gotta have a gang because
if you're just sitting at home like
where is he where is he where is he and
then he comes home and he looks like
he's just gotten beaten up and you're
like hey let's go do this and this you
need to paint the bedroom and do that
it's going to blow everything up so you
got to have a group of friends that that
gives you that connectivity that outlet
because there's gonna be some gaps in
your relationship just because his focus
is going to be on law school it's gonna
be hard yeah okay and I'm also a
studying actuary so I have to study for
big exams too so I'll be studying with
them but not as much as he is you're an
actuary I am oh your your dinner table
conversations are going to be riveting
[Laughter]
just just riveting is he going into
contract a lot please say yes no he
wants criminal ah I was gonna say y'all
would be the single healthiest most
boring couple that has ever lived but
alas he's totally more exciting than I
am that's okay he needs you in his life
desperately
um desperately all right here's the last
thing I'm going to tell you
um
I want you all to and this is going to
sound awful and very not cool for for
some first uh first year of marriage
okay okay I want you all to put
dates
and sex on the calendar
okay build it into your life
build intimacy into your world because
if you wait for it just to happen like
most newlywed couples do they get shoved
in a one bedroom apartment and they're
like hey you're gonna watch Netflix I
don't know you want to make out like
that won't happen in y'all's lives
because you're every minute of y'all's
lives are gonna be so prescribed already
okay and um
law school is an intimate
um it's an intimate Endeavor what does
that mean it means you're talking about
murder cases and rape cases and you're
talking about
um uh people who are hurting the
conversations are deep and talking about
ethics it's very common for people to
fall head over heels for somebody
because you're talking about deep things
that you never talk with anybody else in
the whole wide world
it's a deep exchange of ideas it's not a
thing to be scared of it's a thing for
y'all two to know we are going to
prioritize us over all this other crap
okay and we're gonna put stuff on the
calendar we always go to breakfast every
Saturday no matter what we always go on
a date every Saturday night no matter
what we always we start Tuesday nights
and Thursday nights for all year like
whatever y'all do but we're gonna put it
on the calendar and we're gonna do our
best especially that first year to not
not budge from it we're going to put it
even if it's perfunctory and we just got
to get through tonight we're gonna put
it on the calendar and we're gonna make
it a part of our Lives because we're
going to we are never going to forget
that the main thing in both of our Lives
is us and if I gotta quit law school to
preserve us I'm going to quit Law School
and if I've got to stop playing with
Actuarial tables I'm going to stop doing
that because this is about us is that
you hear what I'm saying and then the
final final thing is if at all possible
stay away from alcohol both of you
okay just stay away
um a few things in the world get law
students into more trouble than alcohol
okay like when I look at all the issues
um distilling down one of the key
factors was that and it usually starts
with and again he's going to be at a
faith-based law school so it may be it
may be more limited there
um and it's been several years since I
was going to work in a law school it's
been five or six years since I was there
but
um alcohol just was was at every event
every everything all the time everywhere
globally just across the culture it's
just it's just pervasive in that culture
um and so having different types of
outlets different ways of having fun
different ways of connecting to other
people just keep a close close eye on
that stuff
that sound all right
amazing thank you so much for your input
let me say one more thing
this is supposed to be hard and our
culture needs brilliant hard smart
lawyers
and so I tell you all this stuff to tell
you not to scare you away to not sit
down tonight and be like I don't want
you to go to law school not that
because we need lawyers and I need
people to clean sewers and I need people
who are
um work in the who do work at funeral
homes I need police officers we need
people to do hard jobs teachers
but that means we have to create a
culture we have to create a life so they
can repel in and do those hard jobs and
so it's not to scare you away from it I
want you guys to go do this I want you
guys to be well and whole and have a
great marriage on the back end which is
a hundred percent possible
I I had dinner with two of my former law
students the other day Jefferson and CJ
two amazing men who are married to
amazing women if they were with in law
school great great you just got to be on
top of it you got to talk it through and
you gotta be highly highly intentional
highly intentional amazing let me know
how he does first semester uh we'll be
rooting for man that's awesome and Shay
he's really really lucky to have you in
his corner thank you for loving him and
thinking through this way way in advance
that's amazing we'll be right back
hey good folks it's that time again
school is back in session it's time to
get back to the routines we threw out
the window in May gotta get up early
drop your kids off pick your kids up and
no more ice cream for dinner your
schedules are about to go Bonkers with
games concerts helping with homework and
a hundred other things but I've got an
important reminder for you please
please make sure you prioritize your
sleep for your kids for your marriage
for your work for you getting seven to
nine hours of deep rejuvenating sleep is
one of the best things you can do for
your physical mental and emotional
health and for me good sleep starts with
a great mattress and that's why I love
dream Cloud mattresses and right now
dream cloud is making it easy with an
incredible deal just for our listeners
40 off all mattresses plus an additional
fifty dollars in savings go to
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
John deloney today that's
John deloney
all right we are back let's go out to
Chris in Huntsville what's up Chris
hey Dr John how are you doing I'm
rocking on to the break of dawn what are
you doing
oh just Sitting Waiting for the kids to
get out of school
[Laughter]
good times just
that sounds sad Chris can't you be like
take disco dance lessons online or
something come on yeah I know I need to
I Knew first day back so all right all
right you get one day all right so
what's up how can I help
um
overcome crushing self-doubt
um I'm feeling overwhelmed with making
some major life decisions
um I've been a stay-at-home mom for the
last
15 plus years and want to return to work
so I can get out of my abusive marriage
um
I had a work colleague recently reach
out to me to um
uh help me get a job
um and I've been extended an offer but
I'm quite scared to take it because I'm
not sure that I'm qualified or I'm going
to be able to do it
and I'm just um really scared that I'm
gonna fail I don't want to let my kids
down
hmm
[Music]
tell me about this marriage
lots of uh silent treatment
um getting punished for
I don't even know what not saying the
right thing or not doing the right thing
um they'll go days or weeks without
speaking to me
um
a lot of violent outbursts not laying
hands on me but throwing things around
and
kick the dogs a couple of times and um
just
uh it's
this is and you just he just says
bad things for kids too and I just so I
know that have you moved out
no we're still together
So when you say to get out of a bad
marriage or is step one getting this job
and securing finances and step two
moving out
yes okay does he know that or is this
just in internal
internal he doesn't know it okay
um
number one I supplied you
thanks
and you and I could probably talk for
another couple hours on this but
these almost always have an escalating
Trend to them and something tells me
that this has become something you can't
do anymore
yeah I think it's
on me yeah my guess is it's probably
fast killing you
and you've got two
um
two big bricks in your backpack number
one is stay-at-home moms are routinely
told that they are dumb and useless and
a drain on society and they should if
they had real worth they would go get
jobs and make real dollars that's that's
that's a global Society problem we have
it's nonsense and it's Insidious and
it's stupid but that's the way it is the
second thing is you've been married to a
a gigantic five-year-old child
who acts like a brat and
um a violent brat and who throws things
and kicks things and swears at things
like like a child does
yeah in the process you have tried
for how long have y'all been married
16 years I've tried for 16 years
to be whatever he needed you to be so
he'd stop doing that
yeah and you're just now realizing oh
it's not me it never has been
yes exactly and so
when a confidence is a contrary to what
Tick Tock will tell you confidence is
not something you can just conjure
confidence is known inside your body
when it knows it can do a thing
and your confidence has been rattled to
the core because you've been trying to
figure out what you're doing so wrong
all these years and you don't have that
confidence
okay so in these initial weeks and
months and years as you are getting your
footing new firm footing on new concrete
sidewalks when you've been swimming in
muck and water and goo the last 16 years
what we're gonna do for a season is
we're going to Outsource that confidence
okay
and I'm always telling people not to
Outsource their life but in this case
it's a little bit different
here's who you're going to Outsource it
to
a business is only in business if it
makes money
and so a good manager will hire the best
people
so that the business makes money so that
the business can continue
and they looked at you
and they said she can help us
and so where you don't have confidence
know that they're not doing you a favor
they're not hooking you up that's not
how business works yeah
right if it was a church or a non-profit
maybe maybe they're trying to help you
out yeah this is a business
and they picked you
and so in the moments when you think I
can't do this remember they do
yeah they think I can
and by the way you've been a parent to
how many kids
two you've raised two humans and you've
protected them from a third giant child
for 16 years you can do just about any
freaking thing you want to do
and can I tell you one more thing yes oh
God you're gonna screw up so much
screw up so much yeah because you don't
you've been out of the workforce you got
to learn
yeah I'm really scared
at least setting myself up for failure
yeah so let me tell you this don't be
scared about it because it's 100 gonna
happen you're gonna happen yeah it's
gonna happen so yeah it's like if if
I saw some data day another day that
said
I don't remember I saw this but it's
pretty powerful
um people will do anything
to avoid uncertainty right so a 50
chance that something's going to go
great or a 50 chance Something's Gonna
go wrong they would rather take the
percentage that a hundred percent of
things are going to go wrong
then live in the ambiguity that half
might go right half might go good which
statistically is insane that doesn't
make any sense right that's like I'd
rather be 100 bad then this could go
really great or it could go really bad
so I'm telling you there's a hundred
percent chance that you screw stuff up
and yeah there's a hundred percent
chance I have screwed things up today in
my job
and that's okay
that's all right
all of us yeah that's part of doing
business that's part of the Great lie of
people outside of business who are
stay-at-home moms are like oh I could
never go do that because I don't have
the dude no we're all making it up as we
go
oh yes you're gonna learn some
incredible new skills and you're going
to transform your life and I told this
story several times have you heard me
tell a story of my mom
actually I have no okay
um
she was not allowed no sorry it's okay
she wasn't allowed to go to college
okay for a whole host of reasons but she
wasn't allowed to go
so she got married to my dad who was a
homicide detective and she just settled
into being a stay-at-home mom and then
she transitioned to working a
stay-at-home mom and then like worked a
few hours a week at a local church like
in the craft office like making sure the
the construction paper is where it
needed to be and the pipe cleaners were
in the right drawer stuff like that
right and then she
um my dad was always encouraging her
please go to school please go to school
please go to school and finally at 42
she got the courage to go back I was a
freshman I think or maybe a um maybe a
sophomore I think a freshman in high
school
she took her first community college
class and got an A and she went the next
semester and took one more class at a
local just down the street from our
house Community College
yeah that was a 42. yeah at 57 she
graduated with her PhD after working at
Enron and deloitten touch before those
two companies imploded
and right now she's in her 70s she just
had her birthday and she had her
birthday in Oxford this is her last
summer to teach at Oxford before she
retires from being a professor for good
wow and she's in her 70s here's why I
tell you that amazing
you can do anything
yeah and there was a ton of bumps and
bruises along the way I thought my whole
world had been turned upside down
because my mom walked in and she said
hey come here and she took me into the
laundry room and she put the thing of
soap on the washing machine and said
this is how this works and from here on
out you're on your own and I was like No
And you know what I lived I lived
right yeah I had to get a job I lived
not only did I live but I benefited from
all that stuff
yeah and so your life will change it
will be very different and if you leave
your husband too it's going to be mess
it's going to be heartbreak even though
it's the right thing all those things
you're in a row like you're headed down
a road it's a very very tough road yeah
okay yeah you got to get people in your
life that you trust
for those moments when you have to
Outsource that confidence yes you got to
get people in your life that you trust
for when you simply don't have the
skills for what comes next and you can
learn them
yeah had you ever before your um your
oldest went to middle school had you
ever been the parent of a middle
schooler
no no you learn how to do that right
right you know how to do that yeah yeah
figured it out you ever like know how to
I don't know fix a weird rash on
somebody's butt crack no never do I had
to figure that out so it happens when
you have kids right you figured it out
you did it yes right yes you will figure
this out too
okay
gonna try I'm gonna try no no hold on
you will
here's the uh one of my favorite
um definitions of imposter syndrome
is I've heard of it yeah it's the fear
that other people are judging me as
harshly as I'm judging myself
can I ask you one hard hard question
yes yes
and tell me if I'm wrong okay
do you doubt yourself because you've
stayed too long
yeah yeah that's partly the reason
is there a reason Chris feels like Chris
let Chris down
or worse you calculate your kids down
yeah I feel really stupid for doing
staying
and letting it get to this point okay
are we done now
yeah we're done okay so let's say
we did stupid things not we're stupid
yeah okay right there's a big difference
guilt is man that was dumb
shame is I am dumb
and you're not dumb you're a woman who
tried to love her husband the best she
could you try to keep your family intact
you try to make sure your kids had a mom
and a dad and you had a husband that
would not let that freaking happen
yeah
and is increasingly putting you in
unsafe unsafe unsafe situations yeah
yeah
that's true that's heroic it's Brave
it's not stupid
yeah okay
yeah has it gone on too long probably
yeah
cool uh yeah yeah it is
um I think it's he knows I'm about the
about a job and he's I think he's
getting nervous so
um
yeah oh that makes me sad
oh so he he tries to change Behavior but
I know that that doesn't ever change so
I've had 16 years to see that so
listen
um whenever you change the equilibrium
in a home
yeah it always does whatever it can to
drag it back to what it was right right
so I'd expect the volume to get like if
nice guy doesn't work then loud guy will
will show up then Timber tantrum guy
will show up yep and I want you to have
some people in your life that you can
call when you need to go
yeah yeah do you have that
I do good it would be difficult but I do
okay every step of the way 100 chance it
will be difficult yeah like it's going
to be difficult so let's just get that
out of the way and then we're gonna go
do what we got to do okay keep our kids
safe keep our ourselves safe keep our
family safe yeah yeah
I'm very very proud of you Chris I'll be
with you every step of the way I want
you to hang on the line I'm going to
send you both of my books my brand new
one
um building a non-anxious life it's it's
kind of what you're talking about how do
I just build something completely new
in a way that there's peace in my house
there's warmth in my house there's
laughter back in my house
there's just not this constant pulse of
electricity I'm gonna send you my first
book own your past change your future
which is about what do you do when it
all falls apart
how do I process what happened when I
was a kid dealing with that old trauma
and then how do I cast that forward and
create something completely new I'm
gonna send you both of those books as my
gift call anytime and I'll walk with you
you got a hard hard road ahead of you
I'm a hundred percent sure you can do it
proud of you Chris when you don't have
confidence in yourself
know at least one knuckleheaded
podcaster does
and I promise you there's a whole bunch
of other folks too we'll be right back
[Music]
hey what's up Dr John deloney here check
it out my new book building a
non-anxious life is now available for
pre-order here's the great news anxiety
is not the enemy we've been led to
believe I know this because I've walked
alongside countless folks over the last
two decades and I've struggled with this
too if you create a life of
intentionally living out the six daily
choices I've outlined in this book
you're gonna be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you you're
going to learn the choices you can make
day by day to create a more peaceful
joyful less chronically stressed
non-anxious life plus when you pre-order
my book I want to give you something to
help you today that's why you'll
instantly get my newest talk smoke fire
and freedom that I gave to several
thousand folks a few months ago where I
break down the misunderstandings and
myths we believe about anxiety how to
reclaim your freedom and how to build a
non-anxious life so pre-order building a
non-interest life today for just 20
bucks at John deloney.com
all right we are back Jenna what's the
big announcement here yes so first off
two things one last night brought home
my first puppy not a dog mom but you're
a pet owner you're a pet owner not a dog
what's the dog's name her name is maple
Kelly I didn't hear you it's Kelly Kelly
yeah that's the dog's name Maple she's a
little wiener dog little Maple sausage
um so I'm not a dog mom but I will be a
real mom February next year
very cool dude congratulations thank you
uh boy girl you know uh my mom knows um
and my husband's mom knows but we do not
know yet we'll find out in a month
well they know like because they've read
the TV we looked at the results oh they
got the blood test they have the results
so we're gonna do a gender reveal reveal
party in a month and we'll and then
we'll know
right when I thought you were going to
be all grown up then you're like no I'm
still Millennial oh absolutely at least
for the first one blue smoke or whatever
I hope it's pink but we'll see
all right I think John
Taylor Swift Sears is a great name
hashtag just saying I'll have to think
about that awesome well in honor of
um your new baby song of the day is from
this is literally one of my favorite
songwriters of all time ever in the
history of the world
um if you don't know his music I want
you just to when this podcast is over
just
um get on Spotify and listen to
everything Mark Cohn c-o-h-n has ever
done he's the best of the best of the
best he's so amazing
um the song I can't believe we've never
done Mark Cohn on this out like for
three years he's one of the best ever
God Almighty my friend Trevor Moore is
the one who introduced me and
he said he saw him play and he said he
went home and bought every CD he'd ever
made like done I picked him because he's
phenomenal I know you don't have this
tattoo though
maybe I do
Mark Cohn would be a weird Old English
tattoo which most of yours are that
would be weird alright so the song is
called the things we've handed down it
goes like this
don't know much about you don't know who
you are we've been fine without you but
we could only go so far don't know why
you chose us were you watching from
above is there someone there that knows
us said we'd give you all our love will
you laugh just like your mother will you
sigh like your old man well something
skip a generation like I've heard they
often can are you a poet or a dancer a
devil or a clown or a strange new
combination of the things we've handed
down congratulations Jenna we have
another another
crazy in the John deloney show Gang
I don't think you shouldn't let your kid
listen to this show for a long long time
love you guys stay in school no new
drugs bye